لم يرد رئيس المكسيك
السيسي نفذت الولايات المتحده ضربات
استهدفت خلالها اربعه زوارق مسيره وسبع
صواريخ كروز بالبحر الاحمر من جانب
الحوثيين دول الاتحاد الاوروبي تقرر
التوجه بشكل عاجل الى البحر الاحمر وزعيم
حكومه صنعاء يتحدث عن كارثه عبريه يجرى
تحضير لها موسكو تصرح واشنطن ولندن لن
تتمكن من تدمير الامكانات العسكريه للجيش
اليمني والبحريه الامريكيه تعلن عجزها عن
حفظ الامن في البحر الاحمر باجتماعات سريه
خطوه كبرى تتخذها السعوديه بشان الحرب في
القطاع العراق يقدم شكوى ضد الولايات
المتحده في مجلس الامن الدولي وموقع عبري
جنود تل ابيب يبيعون اسلحتهم واشنطن تواجه
تحضيراتها لتل ابيب والمانيا تستمد طاقتها
للمره الاولى من الجزائر قياده اوروبيه
تصرح نحن لا نملك عصا سحريه لكي نعطي
اوكرانيا المزيد وكابوس تشالز بدا يتحقق
وزيلينسكي يتخذ قراره الاخير بعد تردد
كبير موسكو تكشف عجز واشنطن ابو اليمن
يسبب الصداع للاوروبيين هنا افادت مجموعات
ار ان دي الاعلاميه الالمانيه ان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي اتفقت على تفاصيل المهمه
العسكريه المشتركه لمنع هجمات اليمنيين
على السفن المار عبر البحر الاحمر واضافت
ان دول الاتحاد الاوروبي شاركت في الاتفاق
العاجل حتى لا تنتظر الاجتماع الوزاري في
بروكسل وكان مدير قسم الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا في وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
الكساندر كين شااكر في مقابله مع وكاله
سبوتنيك انه من غير المرجح ان تتمكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا من
تدمير الامكانات العسكريه للجيش اليمني
ولن تؤدي الهجمات على اليمن الا الى
المزيد من التصعيد في المنطقه ومشاكل في
نقل البضائع البحريه العالميه بينما كانت
امريكا قد جنت غاره على منطقه الشبكه
شماليه محافظه الحديده في اليمن لتفيد
قناه المسيره اليمنيه بان غارات جويه
استهدفت منطقه راس عيسى بمديريه الصليف
اكبر مديريه الحديده غرب اليمن من جانبه
اعلن الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه ميرسك للشحن
فنسنت كليرك ان البحريه الامريكيه ابلغت
الشركه انها غير قادره حاليا على ضمان
سلامه ملاحه كل السفن في البحر الاحمر
لتعلن الشركه تراجع ارباحها بنسبه 87%
خلال الربع الاخير من عام
2023 مقارنه بنفس الفطره من العام السابق
ولنتصور
[موسيقى]
هناك قال زعي حركه انصار الله الحوثيين
عبد الملك الحوثي ان تل ابيب تحضر ل نكبه
في رفح بمشاركه طائره امريكيه وبريطانيه
وخرج ضابط كبير بالجيش العبري مصرحا ان
القوات العبريه تفكك البنيه التحتيه
للفصائل في خان يونس وذلك بعد اكثر من
شهرين من دخولها المدينه الرئيسيه جنوب
القطاع مضيفا ان القوات العبريه تعتقد ان
يحيى السنوار زعيم الفصائل في القطاع
مختبئ هناك وهنا نتصفح
المصدر فيما قال بيت الابيض ان ايه من
عبري على رفح في ظل هذه الظروف سيكون
كارثه هذا وصرحت السيناتور الامريكيه
اليزابيث وورن انه لا مزيد من الشيكه على
بياض لنتنياهو عربيا قالت وسائل اعلام
عبريه ان السعوديه تستعد لاستضافه قمه
تفضي الى موقف عربي موحد بشان الحرب في
القطاع بالاضافه الى مبادرات لما تم
تسميته اليوم التالي لنهايه الحرب وقال
دبلوماسيان عربيان كبيران لصحيفه تايمز
اوف اسرائيل ان المؤتمر يعقد يشارك فيه
وزراء خارجيه خمس دول فقط في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والتي لعبت دورا رئيسيا في تسجيل
المحادثات بين تلابيب والفلسطينيين الى
العراق حيث قال مستشار رئيس الوزراء
العراقي ان الضربات الامريكيه خرق غير
مبرر للسياده العراقيه مضيفا سنقدم شكوى
الى مجلس الامن بشان الضربات الامريكيه
بالعوده الى حرب القطاع ووفق ما جاء في
تقرير لموقع كالك ليست العبري فقد لجئ
جنود احتياط في جيش تلبيب لبيع معداتهم
القتاليه بحثا عن المال بينما يقوم اخرون
بشرائها لان جيشهم لا يوفر لهم احتياجاتهم
واضاف التقرير ان بعض الاسلحه المعروضه
للبيع على الانترنت مسروقه من الجيش
العبري ولنضع المصدر
هنا بعيدا عن اجواء المعارك والحروب افادت
وكاله بلومبرج الامريكيه باشاره رئيس شركه
الغاز الالمانيه في ان جي اولاف هيت مولر
بتوقيع الشركه الالمانيه عقدا مع سونا
تراك الجزائريه المملوكه للدوله للحصول
على اول امدادات الغاز الالمانيه عبر خط
انابيب من الجزائر وتعمل شركه النفط
والغاز الحكوميه الجزائريه سونا تراك في
استخراج ومعالجه ونقل وبيع الهيدروكربونات
وتعد الاكبر في افريقيا في هذا المجال
فيما تعمل في ان جي في قطاع الغاز والبنيه
التحتيه للغاز مع 20 شركه تابعه في
المانيا واوروبا ويقع مقرها الرئيسي في
لايز
بيت اوروبا
تتملص ضربت روسيا الكثيفه المتتاليه اجبرت
كياف على شراء المقاتلين فقد افادت وكاله
اوشيت بريس بان مئات المرتزقه من كولومبيا
ينضمون الى صفوف القوات الاوكرانيه وذلك
على خلفيه تقلص اعداد هذه القوات بسبب
خسائرها على الجبهه خلال عامين من القتال
بينما قالت صحيفه نيويورك بوست الامريكيه
ان الجيش الروسي يقوم بقصف وتدمير
المستودعات التي تحتوي على اخر بقايا
اسلحه القوات الاوكرانيه بضربات دقيقه
واضافت الصحيفه ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تحاول توفير كل قذيفه لان ذخيرتها على وشك
النفاد وروسيا تحاول تعزيز تفوقها
واستهداف ما تبقى في مستودعات المعدات
والاسلحه والذخيره الاوكرانيه ليصرح رئيس
دبلوماسيه الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزف بوريل
على قناه رادا التلفزيونيه الاوكرانيه
خلال زيارته بان الاتحاد الاوروبي استنزف
مخزون نه العسكريه ولا يملك عصا سحريه
لاعطاء اوكرانيا المزيد من القذائف لنعد
الى كياب وبعد ان اعلن وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني روستوم يروف في حسابه على منصه
اكس اعفاء قائد القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
فاليري زالو جني من منصبه اصدر الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي قرارا بتعيين
الفريق الاول الكسندر سرسكي قائدا جديدا
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وخلفا لزال
وجني ووصف زيلينسكي القائده الجديده بانه
الجن ر الاكثر تمرسا في اوكرانيا ياتي هذا
القرار بعد تردد كبير واشاعات كثيره في
الفتره الاخيره ليفعلها زيلنسكي
اخيرا في المانيا كابوس تشارس بدا يتحقق
بسبب الكونجرس الامريكي فقد افادت صحيفه
بوليتيكو الامريكيه بان زياره المستشار
الالماني اولاف تشارز للولايات المتحده لن
تكون ناجحه لانه لن يكون قادرا على اقناع
الكونجرس بالتصويت لصالح المساعده
لاوكرانيا الامر الذي سيجعل المانيا في
الواقع المانح الرئيسي لكيا ميدانيا اعلنت
الدفاع الروسيه تكبيد قوه كياف خسائر بنحو
750 عسكريا على محاور القتال خلال 24 ساعه
فيما اعلن وزير الدفاع البولندي فلاديسلاف
كوسيا كايش ان 40 الف من العسكريين
الاوكرانيين يتلقون التدريب على الاراضي
البولنديه لتعود الدفاع الروسيه وتعلن
نجاح عمليه تبادل اسرى مع اوكرانيا بصيغه
100 مقابل 100
[موسيقى]